dr. ben Carson is the Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development obviously
but before that he lived in Baltimore in
fact he spent almost 30 years performing
pediatric neurosurgery at Johns Hopkins
the most famous Hospital in America
which is in Baltimore there's a lot
about the city and we're happy to have
him join us tonight secretary Carson
thank you very much for coming so you
spent a good chunk of your life in
Baltimore it's a sad City I think it's a
city with a lot of promise what does it
need do you think well first of all you
know as a pediatric neurosurgeon I spent
many hours sometimes operating all night
long trying to give children of
Baltimore and other places around the
world a second chance at life and
usually we were successful but a few
days later I was in a horrible dilemma
because some of those kids had to go
back into homes in East Baltimore that
were infested with rats and roaches and
ticks and mold and lead and violence and
I didn't want to send them back
sometimes I would even consider you know
extra tests so they could stay in the
hospital extra day or two but now
fortunately God's given me an
opportunity to do something about it and
that's one of the reasons I'm delighted
to be in this administration you know
while I was there I worked on a lot of
issues with many politicians including
Elijah Cummings you know particularly in
terms of childhood education and
improving the life for the people I
don't think Elijah Cummings is a bad
person I think he actually is working
hard to try to help people and I
certainly don't think President Trump is
a bad person he's working very hard and
it asked him today would you be willing
to work with Elijah Cummings to bring
some relief to the people of Baltimore
he said he would be happy to but in the
meantime it's going to continue with the
programs you know like the opportunity
zones which get people to take money and
invest it into the areas that are
distressed or 149 of them in Maryland
and you know Governor Hogan is doing a
good job of helping to capitalize upon
that but also you know unemployment is
at a very low level Manufacturing is
coming back wages are going up you know
prison reform all these things are
happening these are not things that a
person who was a racist would do and we
allow ourselves to be distracted
by these things and I think what
President Trump was trying to say is
that rather than spending your time
talking about you know our brave border
agents and investigating endlessly
things that you can't find anything on
why not spend some time working more for
these people you know who are suffering
and that he's willing to work with them
I think that's what we should be asking
for I wonder if a city in which 65
percent of all kids are growing up in a
single-parent household I wonder if you
can get anywhere without addressing that
you you need to address that you need to
address the family issues you know there
was a poverty study by the Brookings
Institute and it concluded after a
massive study that there were three
things a person could do the reduced
likelihood of poverty to 2% of the last
number one finish high school number two
get married
number three wait until you're married
to have children but a lot of our
policies over these decades have not
reflected that in fact have moved us in
the opposite direction we should
actually utilize the data it would make
a huge difference that's I'm so glad to
hear you say that it's an obvious point
and you can't say it enough and it's
rarely said unfortunately secretary
Carson thanks very much
always a pleasure Tucker